we're going to check in in orlando with
jared greenberg
and steve smith guys take it
all right we got dwight howard with us
after a game one laker victory it's
been more than a decade since you've
been here how does it feel oh man it's
this
amazing feeling and i'm just very
grateful to
to have this opportunity to play in the
finals it means so much to me
and uh game one is out the way
uh i think all of us had a little nerves
in the beginning of the game
but once we got settled into the game uh
i think it was all
it was great for us after that dwight
like you said they jumped on y'all they
came out with a 13 point lead what was
the adjustment what was the timeout like
and
what did you guys decide to do to change
the rhythm of the game
we had to be more aggressive on both
ends of the floor i think we came out a
little slow
uh we looked a little tired you know so
we have to pick our energy up
and uh the second quarter especially the
third quarter when we came i want to
play with a lot of energy
and jump on them right from the
beginning and give them no hope and
uh we did a good job of that dwight
there has been so much made this year
of you making a role adjustment and
being okay with going to the bench
and playing whatever role coach vogel
needed you to do how do you then flip
the switch in the western conference
finals
now into the nba finals where coach says
after all this time coming off the bench
you've got to start uh well you just as
steve know you got to always be prepared
you never know when your number's going
to be called
and you know as a vet you know
you could you could either decide to you
know be upset at the coach and say man i
should start you know i got this i
i've been here i've done that but none
of that stuff matters you know that's in
the past
right now we have a chance to win and i
know that in order for us to win
in order for me to get on the floor i
got to play as hard as i can whenever my
number is called
and that's what i try to provide for
this team is energy effort and uh just
be a voice
you know be loud on defense uh be
aggressive
and then just enjoy this moment you know
uh ten years is a very long time you
know
not being in the finals you know and
there's some players who've never had
opportunity to play in the finals you
know so i understand how
uh this moment is you know how you got
to take advantage of it have you shared
that with any of the young guys who
just their first few years in the league
or all of us find themselves in the
finals
we actually talked about this around
this time period last year
when the season had just started right
uh in china we were talking about how
to seize the moment you know you never
know when your numbers call and
you never know what could happen
anything so you know stay
in the moment you know that's the
biggest thing is stay in the moment and
stay ready
when you look at this game y'all came
out and obviously jumped on that 21-5
run but it's just one game now look into
game two
what's the adjustments for you you saw
that you can uh make a little bit of
difference
going out there for game two stay
aggressive on the defensive end stay
aggressive be up be active be loud
try to get every rebound holding the one
shot
make sure that shooters don't get clean
looks at the basket
and just be a voice you know we have two
of the greatest scores
in the league on our team and they're
going to carry the load you know so
uh whenever you know they need a break
you know make sure that we're there
on the defensive end for for those guys
so that's why i just trying to be the
best
you know for my teammates on the
defensive end when you look at it dwight
everybody talked about their zone you
guys did a great job of penetrating
kicked it out and guys knocked down
shots
yes what was the thought process going
up against their zone that you guys
wanted to attack
that's the three-point shot we want to
make sure our three-point shooters got
easy shots
but also attacking on the glass you know
in the zone it's hard to box out two
guys
two big guys especially in the middle of
the paint so uh and also take away the
three
and uh we just wanted to attack the
glass make it tough for them
to stay in that zone and force them to
have to play man-to-man
which we feel like we have some
match-ups that are favorable for us
dwight tonight lebron james an assist
away from yet another playoff
triple-double
after competing against him for all
these years and now as you said having a
full calendar year
as his teammate does he ever cease to
surprise or amaze you man man lebron
been playing against each other since he
was 15 years old
so i've seen it all from i'm just uh
happy to see that you know
in year 17 he's still able to play at a
very high level
uh and just the fact that he enjoys his
game so much and we enjoy just being
around each other
uh off the court you know we've really
grown you know over these past couple of
months
being here being here in this bubble and
uh
we're like a big family and just to see
him thrive on the court
you know it's it's amazing you know i
tell them all the time i'm very happy
and proud for them
dwight talk to me about you and rondo's
connection seems like y'all got a
special connection oh yeah
yeah i can see you smiling you just seem
connected yeah uh
you know me and rondo we uh the class of
2004
it's only three of us left and it's
actually me run doing andre iguodala
you know so uh for me and doe was just
like man this
is you know this is our last couple
years man let's enjoy it together let's
you know just really break bread and you
know just go out with a bang you know
whatever that may be and
you know he's been here this whole you
know corn this whole bubble experience
and you know he's been lifting me up
when i haven't had those opportunities
to play and then
uh when he broke his thumb you know i
was trying to call him and check on him
every day and then you know inside the
bubble when he got back his
breakfast lunch dinner you know uh the
bus stop and
in the back of the bubble just talking
and watching film and
just all the life experiences that we've
had over the years of being in the nba
and it's been amazing i'm happy to have
a teammate and a friend like rondo
right smitty is a newbie here to the
bubble he's only been out of quarantine
for a couple of days they let him out
i'm on day 71 you're on day 85 i believe
for those watching at home who maybe
haven't really
locked into what this has been like for
nearly three months
how do you describe what this has been
like
man uh well you know what it's been it's
been good make that noise again
it's been it's been really good but also
it's been times where it's like man i
wish i could go home
see my family see my kids and you know
uh just
get some you know get back to some
normal things but at the same time you
know just being here has allowed all of
us
to get to become closer and also to
really find out who we are as
is you know individuals you know because
there's no outside distractions there's
no noise
it's just a team and it's just you you
know so you have that time to go around
and walk and meditate and just be by
yourself
or you can be around your teammates or
you can see hall of famers like
steve smith just walking around you know
so it's michigan state hall of fame
you're talking about
i believe he's a hall of famer
so you know i'm just very thankful for
that opportunity just to be here
um because you know we could have been
somewhere else right you know there's a
lot of stuff going on in our world
and uh we get an opportunity to you know
really just grow as individuals but also
teammates so i'm happy about that
all right well um superman shaq's in our
studio
you have a message for him as we throw
it back to atlanta oh man just shaq you
know i enjoy
uh he's always been one of my favorite
players uh growing up
i'm just happy that you know i'm wearing
a purple and gold like he did and
you know i know he was the focal point
of his team but
i'm being superman in my role doing the
best i can to help bring this
this team a ring so thank you shaq for
all the kind words
i always appreciate you and looking
forward to getting out the bubble and
wrestling with you we'd like to see that
who do you think wins well said got me
about 400 pounds so i'm gonna have
it on it
dwight we appreciate you congratulations
on game one
thank the victory let's go back to our
studio here in atlanta as
we continue our live coverage after the
lakers victory